Lionhead Studios the British team behind
the favor and black-and-white series has
officially closed its doors I'm Lucy and
welcome to your GameSpot news update
speaking to your gamer the Microsoft
spokesperson said we can confirm that
after much consideration over the six
week consultation period with Lionhead
employees we have reached the decision
to close Lionhead Studios we have
nothing but heartfelt thanks for the
team at lion head for their significant
contributions to Xbox and the games
industry employees from the studio have
since posted updates about the closure
on twitter with stuart white tweeting
last day of lion head and Callum
McArthur tweeting getting ready to go to
work a lion head for the last time
hardest thing I've ever had to do best
team ever lion head was founded by Peter
Molyneux in 1996 and was acquired by
Microsoft ten years later the studio was
famous for simulation games like
black-and-white and the movies and of
course the eccentric RPG series fable on
March 7th Microsoft revealed that it had
ceased development on the latest
installment fable legends and was in
discussions to close a studio entirely
so thank you for everything lion heads
and we hope that everyone affected lands
on their feet soon what are your fondest
Fable memories let me know in the
comments below or come find me on
Twitter I'm it Lucy James games for more
gaming news keep it GameSpot